it's Wednesday January seventh and
you're watching gamespot news it's the
first wednesday of the new year just
think about that whole fresh Wednesday
set the tone for all your Wednesday's to
come this year anything is possible Wow
also it's the last day are legally
allowed to wish anybody happy new year
so get it out of the way now happy new
year the tech train keeps on chugging
today with an announcement from Nyko
about adding some real estate to your
PlayStation 4 the data bank is a drive
dock that links the ps4 is internal
storage to a 3.5 inch Bay that sits atop
the console the idea is to let you
expand your storage with more affordable
3.5 inch drives as opposed to the
natively supported 2.5 inch drives if
you really need more room to install
stuff this could be your ticket or you
could just delete a few old game
installs and start forgetting that you
actually played knack you might be
looking to augment your specs on the pc
front once you hear the system
requirements for the witcher 3 wild hunt
at minimum the game requires pcs with 6
gigabytes of memory as well as an intel
i5 processor or equivalent clocked at
three point three gigahertz ideally
you'll have eight gigabytes of ram and a
processor clocked at 4 gigahertz what
you thought rendering that grizzled face
in a big open world would be easy for
the full minimum and recommended specs
read the story at gamespot com / news if
there's one thing that people love
searching YouTube for its music but if
there's two things that people love
searching YouTube for music and
minecraft google has revealed the top
search queries for YouTube in 2014 and
minecraft is near the top of the pops
beating out in order movies frozen Drake
Beyonce PewDiePie happy mmm and Taylor
Swift gaming related search terms and
channels are some of the most popular on
YouTube surprising exactly none of you
but it was only through the intrepid
youtubing of my nephew anders that
minecraft was able to reach such a high
rank well him and like millions of other
people but mostly him alright two quick
hits to round out the show today first
up January continues to be the month of
betas halo 5 guardians is
now evolved is coming next week and now
planetside 2 will be arriving on ps4 in
closed beta on january twentieth after
being delayed from last year interested
folks can sign up at planetside 2 calm
and that legendary gift that destiny
players were going to receive that we
told you about yesterday turns out it's
a legendary weapon this one's an auto
rifle but apparently you can get special
and heavy weapons too neato okay folks
that'll do for today you're in the mood
for a laugh go on over to gamespot com
flash news and watch that clip of Jimmy
Fallon talking about how video games
made things real awkward between him
into Cole kidman it sounds kind of math
but it's actually pretty funny if you
don't believe me